In this video I will be showing you how to create a tic-tac-toe game from start to finish using
JavaScript HTML and CSS. I will also show you how to create the AI using the minimax algorithm.
I expect you to have basic knowledge about HTML CSS and JavaScript
But you don't have to know anything too advanced
However it may take a few rewatches to completely understand the minimax algorithm
If all you are interested in is the minimax algorithm feel free to skip to that section by clicking the link in this description
for section 7. To get the most out of this video you should create the tic-tac-toe game along with me on your own computer
If you get lost while writing the code you can check out the github repository that goes along with this video
This video has many sections
And there is a folder in the github
Repo for every section in the video the folder has what your code should look like at the end of each section
Check out this video's description
For links to the code for the each section as well as links to skip ahead to that part of the video
Before we start creating anything
Let's make sure your development environment is set up
an easy way to create this project is to use codepen.io
Just go to the site, and then create a new pen
There is a section to put your HTML your CSS and your JavaScript
And then everything you create will show up right over here. Also. Don't forget to give your pin a name and save it
However I'm actually going to create the project locally on my machine instead you can do that with any text editor
I'm using sublime text. I'm gonna open sublime text, and then go to file open
Now I'm selecting a folder. I already created for this project
inside this project create three files
I use the sidebar enhancement package add-on so I get more options when I right click here
So we're gonna create the three files. We're gonna create Tic Tac Toe.html
Now style.css and
Then the last one is going to be script.js
Tic-tac-toe.html. I'm going to paste in basic HTML boilerplate code
That should be included in most projects. You can see that in the head. There is already a link to style.CSS and
also at the end of the body
There is a link to the script.js javascript file so that's how all these three files that we created are connected
The first thing you should do is insert the title so right inside the title here. I'll put
Tic-tac-toe, and if you're accreting the project in code pen you actually don't need any of this code all of this is
automatically included
Now let's start setting up the basic HTML structure
First of all I want to let you know that just like any programming project there are an infinite ways to create a tic-tac-toe game
There's not really a right way to do it as long as it works
We're going to use a table to create the 9 by 9 grid needed for the tic-tac-toe board
After we get this code in we'll add some CSS to make it look more like a traditional tic-tac-toe board
Now press command shift D to duplicate that three times, and we'll just change this to one this to two and
then command shift D two more times
Three four five six seven eight
We're also going to need to display who is the winner of the game so at the bottom?
We'll add a div with the class of endgame
Also, we'll add a button that will allow the player to reset the game after it ends
While we are putting this at the bottom later. We'll add some CSS to position the in-game message on the top of the tic-tac-toe board
Also, that reset button will eventually go into the in game element next we'll start working on the CSS
Okay before we switch over to our CSS file you can see that
I opened up a browser window right here, and it's going to show everything that we've created right now the table
There's nothing in the table, so it doesn't show the table, but we can see the replay button also
I didn't realize I named one of my files and correctly this was supposed to be script J
S so I'm going to right click and rename now. This is with my special
Add-on here, so not everyone can rename right from in sublime
So now we have the right name script J. S not script at CSS. Okay
We'll go over to our style tab here and the first thing we're gonna style is the TD element
The TD element if we go back into our HTML
That's what all the cells in our tic-tac-toe game all the squares are the TD elements, so we're gonna set up border
And I hide in a width
We'll just stop for a second just to see what that looks like so far
So it's already starting to look like a tic-tac-toe board let's put in a few more things
And let's see what that does I'll save that refresh the page and
Now you can see well. We did add this cursor:pointer, so it looks like you can click each square when you're on it
And you can see it still doesn't look like a tic-tac-toe board exactly so again a few more things for the styling now
I'm going to add some styles to the table element
So that's going to style the whole table element that includes everything else here
So border-collapse:collapse, that's what is going to make it look more like this, so we don't have the two lines for each cell
Now this is just some stuff for positioning. It's gonna make sure it's centered
position:absolute
means it's not going to be related to other things on the page and
The left fifty percent and then margin left negative 155 pixels is just a way to Center it so it's gonna
move
50 percent to the left and if we just if we didn't have the margin left with the edge would be at the center
So if I take that out and then refresh that you can see the edge is right in the center
But we have to move it back over so the negative 155 pixels the whole
thing is
310 pixels
divided by 2 is
155 so that's why we go negative 155 pixels left
And the top 50 is just so there'll be some space at the top because it's absolute now
It's not related to where this button is so this button just pops up at the top
Now we want to make this look more like a tic-tac-toe game by removing the edge border all the way around
We're gonna use the first child selector
So let's see what this would actually select table T our first child TD so first
We're gonna go to the table, and then the T our first child so there's the first child
This is the second child
This is the third child so we're only
selecting the first child which is basically the whole top row here and
TD. Which is going to which will be every TD element so for every square in this first row here
We're going to do something
Border top equals zero, let's save there and refresh that page you can see now there's not a border on top
So I'm just gonna copy this
Scroll down here
Let's copy this. Let's get that more toward the top here so we have more room
Pasted here, so now instead of first child we're going to do last child
It's a border top and a border bottom, and then if we just look what that looks like we just removed the bottom
Now we're gonna. Just change this up slightly
We're gonna cut that and then put it on the end of the TV, so we're gonna
Select every table TR and then just the first child TD so we go back here
This is the first child
This is the first child and this is the first child
Instead of border top it's gonna be border left
And we can see what that's gonna look like and then just the same thing
instead of first child last child and border, right
Okay now it's starting to look like a tic-tac-toe board
Now I'm just gonna add some code. That's going to
Style, this this in-game element this in-game element is gonna look like a little a modal that pops on top of the tic-tac-toe board
At the end of the game, so let me add code for that
Okay now I got this whole end game element you can see we have it
display:none
Because it's not going to display until the end of the game and actually just to see what it looks like let's just remove this
Display:none for a second and see what that's gonna look like see it's gonna. Just pop on top just like that
And let's put that back
Again, you can change styling any way you want to make it look a little more exciting than what I'm doing
Now we're gonna finally get into the JavaScript code the JavaScript part of this video is broken up into four sections
First we're going to set up some variables and add the ability to click a square and show a mark
Second we are going to add logic to determine the winner and show the winning combination
Third we'll create a very basic AI and add the code to notify who the winner is and finally and this is the most complicated
section will create the logic for an unbeatable AI
Using the minimax algorithm. I'll demonstrate how it works with some diagrams
So like I said this first section will set up some variables so first we're gonna initialize the board so
The bar or edge board means original board and this is eventually going to be an array
That keeps track of what's in each square the tic-tac-toe board if it's an X or it's an O or nothing
And now this is how will show that the human player is going to be
0 and we'll have also have a Const of the AI player which will set to X
Now you can create these as anything
It doesn't even have to be X and O and it'll show up in the boards over there
and now we're going to create an array that's going to show the winning combinations for the tic-tac-toe board and
Inside this each winning combination is going to be an array so it's an array full of arrays
So we have 0 1 2 so each square
This is square 0 this is Square 1
and this is square 2 if if we have oh-o-oh across that would score for tic-tac-toe and
The other two ways to win across
0 3 6 this would be 0 3 6 so that would be a diagonal win and
Now I just put the other winning combinations in there
so cells equals document dot query selector all and
Dot cell and let's zoom out a little bit so that means the cells
Variable is going to store a reference to each cell here
Document that query selector all is going to select each
Element on the page that has the class of cell which are all these TD elements
and then we're gonna have to call a function to start the game, which is just gonna be the start game function and
Now we've defined the function so this is what will happen when the game starts
Also one thing to point out is that remember when you click replay?
It's also going to run the start game function so this start game function will run at the beginning
But also whenever you click replay it will run the start game function
We have the document dot query selector, and we're going to select the in game element
And we're going to set the style so we're gonna modify the CSS style
Specifically the display property we're going to set the display property to none
Now if we go back into the style you can see that this the display property is already set to none
but
Remember this will also happen when we hit the replay button that will run the start game function and at the end of the game
the in game
Element is not going to be set to display none is actually showing up so when you click replay
It will be set to none again
and now we're going to
Finally load something into the original board variable that we have up here
We're gonna set it to array dot from array 9 dot keys
This is just a fancy way right here to make the array be every number from 0 to 9
so
It's gonna create an array of nine elements
And it's gonna be get just the keys for that element which is 0 through 9 and it's gonna create an array
From that other array, so just to show you what I'm talking about. I'm just going to console that log that here
So if I save that I'm going to run this
Now I'll open up the JavaScript console. You'll see we have an array of Elmas 0 through 8 here
But let's remove this for now
Now throughout the course of the game
We'll actually be adding X and X's and O's to this so whenever we restart the game
We want to remove all the X's and O's from the board
So we're going to do that with a for loop so
We're just gonna go through cells that length and remember cells is this up here
So it's a reference to every cell up here. I'm gonna go through every cell up there
And we're gonna do three things each cell so
Cells eye is gonna be each item of the cell when it loops through this for loop
I'm gonna set the intertext to nothing so there will be nothing in the cell and
We're going to do remove property background color
That's because I already know that when someone wins we're going to highlight each
Square that's part of the winning combination in a certain color
and if the game is restarting we want to remove that background color, so we're back to having no background color and
Then one final thing
We're gonna add an event listener on the click event and we're going to call the turn click function
So now every time anybody clicks one of these things
We're going to call the turn click function and the turn click function is the next thing we're going to define in our program
For now just so you can see what's going to happen we're going to do a console dot log and
Actually inside the trunk click function. We're going to pass in something, so I'm just going to call this square
It's just gonna pass in a click event so we're gonna console that log
Square target dot ID
So now it's just going to log the ID of whatever square was clicked, so I'm going to save this
I'll refresh this page, and then let's see what happens. I'm going to click
Oh, I'm getting an unexpected token. Let's see what I did wrong there says number line 28
Oh
I just forgot to put the word function here, so this is supposed to be a function. Let's save that refresh and
Okay cannot read property remove property
It looks like I spelled this wrong this would be style so maybe you already noticed while it's typing it in earlier
But this is a good way to troubleshoot your code
Just look in the JavaScript console, and they'll give you an idea of what you did wrong so now let's refresh this
That's why it's good to try things out periodically while you're programming so you can catch things quickly
I'm I'm actually gonna clear the console and then refresh so you can see that
There's no errors and now if I click it. Oh six because that's the zero one two three four five six C
I'm gonna click there click there wherever I click you can see in the console
Here's 0 here's 8 you can see it appearing down the console down here
I know it's kind of small, but it's showing the ID of the square that I'm clicking
But we actually don't want it to just console that log every time you click somewhere, so I'm gonna delete this here
And we're gonna call another function
inside the trunk click we're gonna call the turn function and we're gonna pass in the ID that we're clicking and
We're gonna pass in H. You player because it's the human player
That's doing the term so
actually
That's the only thing that's going to be in the turn click function is calling the turn
function and the reason why we don't go directly to the turn function is
because the turn function can be called with either the human player or
The AI player so if a human is clicking we're gonna call the turn function with the human player and not the AI player
So now let's define the turn function
This time I'll remember to put the word function
the turn function is going to take two parameters the square ID and the player and
you can see that's what we pass it up here the square ID and the player this is the human player and
So we're gonna set two things
So first of all we're gonna set the board array or ridge board at the ID that we've clicked to player
So on this array. It's going to show the player who just took a turn in that spot
But we don't actually see that array. We're also gonna have to update the display so we can see where you just clicked
Okay, document dot get element by ID
That's going to select an element with the ID and the square ID if you remember from in the HTML
we have the square IDs here, so we're gonna select the element that was just clicked and
Set the inner text to equal
Player
so if I save that and refresh
if I click here
Wherever I click you can see an oh it pops up
So right now. We can fill that all up, and then that's all we can do, but let's see if the replay button works
Yeah, we can click replay, and we can keep putting an O in here, so this is kind of fun for a few seconds
But I think we need some more functionality of our game here
So now we're entering the second part of the JavaScript section
Which is actually the fifth part of this video where I'm going to add logic to determine the winner and show the winning combination
remember you can check the link in the description of this video to
link to the github repo where you can get the actual code that I'm using and
Remember the folder for each section shows what the code should look like at the end of each section
so if you get the code for the end of section 4
You'll be exactly where I am now so whenever a turn is taken
We are going to check if the game has been won, so I'm gonna add this let
game 1
equals check when and
Check win is going to be another function
We're going to define in just a second, but we're gonna pass in two things the original board array
Which is an array that shows?
everything on the board where the X's and O's are and
The player the current player because we want to check if a certain player has just one
if game one
So if we find that the game has been won called the game over function
With the game one variable you'll see here that this is not just going to be a true or false
Variable we're gonna have some other information that will be passing into the game over function
Okay, now. I will define the check win function which is going to receive the board and
The player the reason why we have to pass in the original board here
And we don't just reference the original board variable in this function is because later in this program
We will be passing in things that are not the original board
There are different versions of the board than what the current version of the board actually is you'll understand that when I get to it
Now this line that I'm typing is really just a fancy way to find all the places on the board
They have already been played in
Let's bring this down to this line here
So we're going to use the reduce method the reduced method is going through going to go through every element of the board array and
do something and it's going to give back one single value the
Accumulator is the value that's going to give back at the end?
And we're going to initialize the accumulator to an empty array
the e is the element in the board array that we're going through and the I's
Index so if the element equals the player
Then this is a ternary operator, so then we're going to do this. We're going to just contact
I that just means we're gonna take the array the accumulator array
and we're going to add the index to that array and
then if
He does not equal player. We're just going to return the accumulator
Just as it was so we're not going to add anything to the accumulator
So this is just a way to find every index that the player has played in
And we're going to set game 1 to equal null and
Then we're gonna check if the game has been one
We're gonna do that with a for loop so?
This is a for
Loop, actually this supposed to be winged combos dot entries so remember at the very top we have the win combos
This is every single thing that could create a win
Every array here could create a win
So we're going to have to loop through every
wind combo every
possible way that a player could can win so
when combos dot entries is just a way to get the index and
the win so we're gonna have one variable that's 0 because this is index 0
That's gonna be the index and the win each win that we're looping through the wind is going to be this array with 0 1
So we're gonna need the index of the winds we need the index and the win in this for of loop
If when dot every when de every means we're going to go through
Every element in the wind so for instance the first one with just every element would be 0 1 2 so
If winda every so for every element in that 0 1 & 2 we're gonna check if
Plays that index of L is more than negative 1 so the plays is from up here
plays is the all the places that the player has played on the board and
Index of so we're gonna see if the index of the element is
more than negative 1
That's just a fancy way of saying of saying has the player played in
Every spot that counts as a win for that win so has the player playing all these spots
And then it's a loop has the player playing all these spots has the player playing all these spots
We go through every single one to see if the players play in all the spots that constitutes a win combo
If so that means the player has won, so we're gonna set game 1
2 equal
Index index player
player
so now we know which wind combo the player won act and
we know which player has won, and now we're just going to break from the function and
After all that we're going to return
game 1 so if nobody wins
Game one will be null if someone does win Game one will contain which when it was and
which player 1, so let's go back up here if
game 1 then run game over if game has no if game 1 is null this will be false if
Game 1 contains this here this will be true
And we'll run the Gamo over function so now let's define the GAMEOVER function
And
The GAMEOVER function is going to accept game 1 our game 1 was defined right up here
And we're gonna pass in here, and that's gonna go into here
Inside the game over function we're gonna have two for loops
first of all we want to highlight all the
squares that are part of the winning combination
And then we want to make it so the user cannot click any more squares because the game is over
Let index of win combos and we're gonna pass in game one index
So that was the index of the winged combo that was the winner for this game
so we're gonna go through every index of that win combo and
We're going to do something
Document dot get element by ID the index
that's the index from the win combo dot style dot background color, so we're gonna set the background color to
Something what we set the background color will depend on who just won the game
Game one dot player. That's who won the game if game 1 dot player equals the human player now
This is a ternary operator. We're gonna set the background color to blue if it's the AI player
we're gonna set the background color to red and
That's the end of this for loop now. We're going to have one more for loop and
Now we're going to go through every cell and we're going to make it so you can't click that cell anymore
So we're gonna remove the event listener
the remove the click event listener, and we have to also pass in what that click event event listener was to the term click and
Set this to false
Okay, so now let's see how this works. We're going to refresh here with all of our new code, ooh
We have some air here missing initializer and destructuring declaration
41 so let's go up there
Hmm oh
We just I think it's just so we have an extra parentheses here. Let's see if that solves the problem
Now let's clear the console and refresh
Unexpected token
44 so let's see what happened there and
Here it looks like
Here I was missing a parenthesis it should be index of element is
less than negative 1, so let's try that we're gonna refresh this and
Another here ok. Let's see what we did here I
Don't think we need this parenthesis, so let's see if that fix the problem I
Think it just fixed the problem, so let's try this out. Okay if we put three in a row
It turns the blue, and we can't click anywhere. Let's replay now
We should be able to click three in a row turns a blue, and we can't click anywhere
Turns a blue. We can't click anywhere so that works
We can now determine a winner next up. We're going to create a basic AI and show the winner box
Well I hope you're still falling along and creating your own program along with my program
We've just started Section six so if you get the code from the github repository
That shows the end of section five you should be caught up with where I'm at now
Again, just check the link in the description for that code right now
There's no AI so the computer doesn't even do anything when you play you're just only putting O's in there
So we're gonna change that in this section this will just be a basic AI
Without the minimax algorithm in the next section. We're going to implement the minimax algorithm
So let's go back up to the turn click function so when the turn click function is
Run the human player is going to take a turn
But right after the human player takes a turn the AI player will take a turn so
Before the AI player takes a turn we're gonna check if it's a tie
So if it's a tie game that means every square is full and nobody has won yet
So if every square is full the computer player is not going to take a turn so if there's not a tie
Then the computer player will take a turn turn
That spot AI player
So just up like up here. We put in the target ID that was clicked here
we're gonna get the ID based on this other function the best spot function is going to return the ID to click and
Instead of the human player we have the AI player taking the turn let's do one last thing while we're in this function
Right now you can click on a place
That's already been clicked so we want to make it so you cannot click on a place. That's already been clicked
so let's add that logic right up here if
typeof a ridge board Square that target dot ID
Equals equals number so if you remember the original board array
Gets filled with the numbers 0 through 9 and then when a turn is taken that
Index will be replaced
Not with a number anymore, but with the X or the O the human player or the computer AI player
so if the type of the ID that was just clicked is a
number that means that neither the human nor the AI player has played in that spot
so if nobody is play in that spot, then let's
Cut those out put it right here, then we'll do this
We'll run the turns here so the human player and then the computer play right there
So you can see we made two functions check tie and best spot
So let's create those functions. Let's go down to the bottom here, and we'll start with the best spot function
Now this is how we're going to find the spot for the AI player to play remember
I said that eventually we'll make it more complicated, but this time. We're just going to make something really simple
So the best spot function is just going to run a different function we still have to create
That's gonna find all the empty squares and just get the first element from the empty square
So it's just always going to play in the first empty squares so before we create the check tie function
Let's finish creating the empty squares function. I'll put it right up here
So function empty squares
So we're going to filter every element in the original board to see if
the type of the element equals a number if the type of is a number we're going to return that
so all the squares that are a number are empty and the squares are an X or an O are not empty and
The best spot is just going to find the first square. That's not empty so
Now like I said, we're going to have that checked eye function
so to check if it's a tie we just use the empty squares function that we just created if
The length equals equals zero that means every squares filled up
And nobody's won yet because normally every time someone plays a turn it check to see if someone's won
So if every square is filled up and nobody is one that means there's a tie we're gonna do a few things
inside a for loop
Because we're gonna do something to every single cell in the tic-tac-toe board
So we're going to set the background color of every cell to green
And we're gonna remove the event listener so the user can't click anywhere right now because the game's over and
We're going to declare a winner. This is actually a function. We sought to create declare winner
Tie game that's what we're gonna pass in the words tie game and return true because
True it's a true that it's a tie or if this if statement is false. We're going to return false
Okay, we just create a new function so now we have to define that function the clear winner let's put that one right up here
Declare
Winner oh
And we've passed in whoo
Right down here. We passed some tie game
But we'll also sometimes pass and if the computer wins or if the human wins
So inside this function we're going to do something
So we're finally going to show
The in game section it was set the style was set to display none
But now it's gonna be set to this display block. I'm just gonna duplicate this line
I'm gonna select that in game dot text
So now if we go back into the HTML
The dot txt he is here so the ink inside endgame and then inside text
That in our we're gonna set the inner text
To who that's what we passed in here so if it's a tie game
It's gonna say tie game
So we also wanted to say if you win, or you lose
so let's go over the game over up here and
When there's a game over?
We're going to also call the declare winner function and we're gonna
Have a ternary operator to see what we're gonna pass into the declared winner function
So if the game won that player is a human player we're gonna pass in the words you win
Else we're going to pass in the words you lose
So I think we're done implementing this basic AI so you can actually play a full game of tic-tac-toe
Let's save it and test and see if we get any ears no error so far. Let's see
Yep, so I played here the computer
I'll I'm going played on the next open spot the computer play on the next open spot, and it says you win
So let's replay now. Let's see if I can get the computer to win
You lose
Now let's see if we can get a tie game
Tie game
So we just saw every in state you win you lose and tie game at
This point you have a fully functional tic-tac-toe game
However as you can see it's pretty easy to beat
Now we will create an unbeatable AI using the minimax algorithm
After we implement the minimax algorithm, you will never see the message you win on the screen
Much of this section on the minimax algorithm is taken by a great article by
Achmed abdul Saheb on the topic I have linked to the article in the description of this video I
definitely recommend you check it out a minim X algorithm can best be defined as a
Recursive function that does the following things one returns a value if a terminal stay is found in this case
Positive 10 zero and negative 10 to go through available spots on the board
3 call the minim x function on each available spot a recursion for
evaluate returning values from function calls and 5 returned the best value
I'm going to go through the code for the minim x function. Don't worry
If you don't completely understand it at first after I show the code
I'm going to use an example and diagram to demonstrate the algorithms function calls one by one
Also, if you're anything like me you may want to watch this section more than once to get a grasp on it before we define
the minimax function will change the best spot function
It's actually just going to return the result of calling the minimax function
it's going to call the minimax function passing in a ridge board and a I player because it's the AI player playing and
It's going to get dot index because the result of the minimax
Function is an object and dot index will be the index at the computer to play in
So we'll define the minimax function with two arguments new board and player
then we need to find the indexes of the available spots in the board using the empty squares function and
Set them to a square called avail spots
We'll check for terminal States
meaning someone winning and return a value accordingly if
Zero wins you should return negative 10 if X wins you should return positive 10
In addition if the length of the available spots array is 0 that means
There is no more room to play the game has resulted in a tie and you should return 0
Next you need to collect the scores from each of the empty spots to evaluate later
Therefore make an array called moves and loop through empty spots while
collecting each moves index and score in an object called move
Then set the index number of the empty spot that was stored as a number in the
original movie
Then set the empty spot on the new board to the current player and
Call the minimax function with the other player and the newly changed new board
Next you should store the object
Resulted from the minimax function call that includes a score property to the score property of the move object
if
the minimax function does not find a terminal state
It keeps recursively going level by level deeper into the game
This recursion happens until it reaches a terminal state and returns a score one level up
Finally minimax resets new board to what it was before and pushes the move object to the moves array
Then the minimax algorithm needs to evaluate the best move in the moves array it
Should choose with the highest score when AI is playing and the move with the lowest score when the human is playing?
therefore if the player is AI player it sets a variable called best score to a very low number and
Loops through the moves array if a move has a higher score than best score the algorithm stores that move in
Case there are moves with similar score only the first one will be stored
The same evaluation process happens when player is heyou player
But this time best score would be set to a high number and minimax looks for a move with the lowest score to store
at the end minimax returns the object stored in best move I
Want to emphasize again that it's okay, if it takes a few
Reviews to understand this I had to go over it multiple times
I first learned it, but this next example should help before we go over the example
Let's actually just try this out just to make sure I didn't make any mistakes when I was creating the code so I save that
Refresh over here and let's see ooh
Reference air or rigid board not defined
JavaScript 76 let's go up to 76 up here and
This should be there's be an eye in there. Okay. Let's save that refresh and let's see if we have any more ears
And this seems to be working
Let's see if it's possible when it's not possible to win they did something right
Okay, gonna, try it out a little more later, but let's go over to the example in this example
We are starting with this board configuration and then following how the minimax algorithm determines the next move
Assume the AI is X and the human players oh
I'm gonna use this figure right here to follow the algorithms function calls one by one remember in this example
We're pretending R at the end of a tic-tac-toe game
So there's just one more move left so the board looks like this
So we're gonna go through the code to figure out the exact logic that the program takes to figure out where to play
so in Figure 1
we're at the very beginning of the minimax algorithm and
a ridge board and the AI player is fed into the algorithm and
The algorithm is going to make a list of the three empty spots that it finds, so if you see right here
We have the spot here here the middle and then the bottom-left
It's gonna check for terminal States, and then loop through every empty spot starting from the first one
here, it's going to
The new board by placing the AI player in the first empty spot after that it's going to call itself
With new board and the human player and wait for the function call to return a value
So we're just on the first function call we're not to the end of the first function call yet
But now we're already going to the second function call
So while the first function call is still running the second one starts?
By making a list of the two empty spots at vines just these two that's here where it's making list of the two empty spots
It's going to check for terminal States, and then loop through the empty spot starting at the first one
Then it changes the new board by placing the human player in the first empty spot after
That it calls itself with new board and the AI player and waits for the function call to return a value
We're at the third function called which is right here
Still function called two and one have not finished the algorithm makes a list of empty spots and this time
It's going to find a win the human player is going to win
therefore it returns an object with the score property and value of negative ten and
Since this second function call up here listed two empty spots
The minimax changes the new board by placing the human player in the second empty spot so B right here
And then it calls itself with the new port in the AI player
so from function two we got two function 3 by placing a spot here in the middle and
Then we go from function 2 to function 4 by placing a spot in on that bottom left
The algorithm is makes a list of four spots the algorithm. Just makes a list of empty spots and
Finds a win for the human player after checking for terminal States
And then it's going to return negative 10 again on
The second function call the algorithm collects the values coming from lower levels the third and the fourth function calls
Since the human player's turn resulted in the two values the algorithm chooses the lowest of the two values on
The second function called algorithm collects the values coming from the lower levels, so we already had the index
and then we're gonna assign the score here and
We're gonna assign the index the new board and then we're pushing all the moves on to the moves array
So that's how all the values have been collected from the third and fourth function calls since the human player's turn
Resulted in the two values the algorithm chooses the lowest of the two values
So here's if the players the AI player else, which is what we're at now because the player is a human player
It's going to run this code to select the lowest of the values
Since both values are similar it chooses the first one and returns up to the first function call
That's down here when it returns moves best move
At this point the first function call has evaluated the score of moving the AI player in the first empty spot
Next it changes the new board by placing AI player in the second empty spot, so this was the first empty spot
here's the second one in the middle it's gonna call itself with the new board and the human player and
I'm gonna skip through some of this of every single thing that happens
But you can see in function call 1 there are three empty spots
And that's why there are
Three and level one so the first empty spots function call to the second empty spot function call five and the third empty spot
Function call six to empty spots here two
moves here and
Here since we found a terminal State. You don't actually go any further and here
There's two empty spots
so we try these two and then eventually you get down to eight and
Because of the recursive nature and like I was showing before this gets passed up to the top now
Toward the end of ring the algorithm the three branches of the first function call have all been evaluated
We got the negative 10 the 10 and the negative 10
But because the AI player's turn
Resulted in those values the algorithm returns an object containing the highest score
Which is the +10 at index 4 which is the middle index?
So in this scenario the minimax concludes that moving the X to the middle of the board results in the best outcome
Now to speed things along I didn't explain every single function call
But if you check the article they link to in the description it goes into even more detail about this
I hope with my explanation and just being able to play with the code a little bit
You'll be able to understand the logic behind the minimax algorithm
Okay, and there's one final thing
I still need to do you can see that the replay button is right up here in the corner
And we want to put it in the popup box
So I'm just gonna go over to the HTML file and I'm gonna select this button and then at least on the Mac
it's control command up, so it's going to move that line up, and then I'm just gonna tab it over and
That should put the button in the right spot, so let's refresh here
And now the replay button doesn't show up until the game is over and you can put the replay button right on that little pop-up
And
You now have an unbeatable tic-tac-toe game?
There are many ways this game can be improved so for extra practice you can think about other
features you can implement for
Instance maybe you want to make it two-player so there can be two human players instead of a human and a computer player
Well, thanks for watching. My name is Bo Carnes. Don't forget to subscribe and remember use your code for good